let's talk to the welsh economy minister
vaughan gething good to see you
this morning good morning i mean this is
a a real moment of confidence in
in the vaccine presumably and how things
are playing out in wales
yes it's a really important step forward
for wales we've continued to be cautious
you'll have heard me
and other ministers regularly say that
about our approach
but there is real confidence the vaccine
is making a significant difference
in the second wave that we went through
in the winter just gone
about ten percent of people with
infections ended up in hospital
now it's a little under two percent so
that is making a huge difference there's
still
significant pressure in our national
health services your piece earlier
showed but it's nothing like the second
wave
of the virus and we've got
extraordinarily high rates here in wales
just under 91 percent of people have had
at least one dose and we've got just
another 83 percent of people on
yesterday's because having had both
doses that's
nearly 9 ahead of the uk average so
we're doing really well in persuading
people to come forward
it's still important if you haven't had
your vaccine
please get yourself vaccinated it'll
protect you and it's the best way to
protect
other people around you as well and give
all of us
the best prospects of not having to go
backwards if this virus does take
another turn for the worse where does
that leave you
in terms of of young people so the the
under 30s are
obviously a real concern as to
the vaccine uptake but where are you
with them
and what more can you do to get them
double jabbed well we've got over 75
percent of our younger people have
already had
at least one dose and we've got about 56
on yesterday's figures have had both
doses so we are getting to the majority
of those people
but we are stalling in the progress so
we're still making progress each day but
not as quick
as we have than with other age ranges
now we're we're not looking to have some
of the incentives that england are
offering you know a kebab for a job i
don't
that's a troubling public health message
in a number of ways but it's still about
persuading that it's the right thing for
them
to do to look after themselves and the
new freedoms that are being unlocked
that we all want to see
kept open for all of us it's really
important that we all do the right thing
to make sure that happens we've got a
range of different people
talking with younger people we've got
young people as advocates talking to
other younger people
and in a range of areas we think that
for international travel for example for
some time to come
you're going to need you to demonstrate
your vaccine status we're also then
moving on
with the vaccination of people who are
18 and under
there's a number of rising 18 year olds
who already having their invites to
vaccination
and people who will now start to receive
16 and 17 year olds in rice to come
forward for their vaccination as well
so the program is doing everything it
could and should do and it's about us
persuading people it's the right thing
for them to do
in terms of vaccine status i mean what's
your position on
on whether you need to extend that to
hospitality or or anything else moving
forward is that something
that the welsh government would consider
well we have considered this we've had
an active discussion
amongst ministers before reaching a
decision and it's still our view that we
shouldn't mandate
vaccination status for access to certain
areas but
as i say international travel the rules
are likely to be for some time to come
but you're going to need you have to
demonstrate your vaccination status to
travel
on hospitality it's one of the
reasonable measures that
a venue could take so some night clubs
some
events already are doing this you're
going to need to demonstrate either
having had a negative
cover test or to have vaccination status
to access
events and a venue itself could decide
that it wants to be able to demonstrate
that status before coming in
or in pre-booking tickets now those
venues will have to consider what
they're going to do
because we've reduced and we've changed
the measures on social distancing
it's a reasonable measure of venue could
take but they'll need to think about
what other measures they can take to
reduce risks
because mask wearing isn't required in
hospitality from today
so the picture's shifting but it isn't a
free-for-all as the first minister said
yesterday so vaccination status not
required by law
but it is a measure that some venues may
introduced
and it's certainly about to be the case
for some time to come in international
travel